[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZEINA OWEIS: So
let's get started.
Hello, everyone, and
thank you for joining us.
It's 5:30 already, or almost.
And we hope that it's
going to be a great wrap up
for your second day at Next.
My name is Zeina Oweis,
and I'm a Product Manager
on the G Suite team.
VISHNU SIVAJI: And
I'm a Vishnu Sivaji,
also a PM on the same team.
ZEINA OWEIS: And
Vishnu and I are
very aware that we're standing
between you and happy hour.
That was publicized just now.
But we've promised to
make it worthwhile.
In the next hour, we're
going to demonstrate ways
that G Suite apps like
Docs, Sheets, Slides, Gmail
and Drive, as well, can
help you close more deals
in as little time as possible.
And that just means doing your
best work, but a lot faster.
As a professional in
a sales organization,
you're always striving
to boost your efficiency,
increase conversions, sell
more, things like presentations
or pitch decks like
these are just tools
to help you achieve that goal.
Similarly, emailing back and
forth, setting up meetings
are just means, and not the end.
But unfortunately, these means
take up a lot of your time.
In fact, we know
that, on average, reps
spend only one third
of their time selling.
The remaining two thirds are
spent, mainly, on two things,
creating presentations, pushing
boxes around on a slide deck,
and doing administrative work
like communicating and setting
up meetings.
Two thirds of your time is
not spent with your clients,
not spent prospecting
new clients,
and product managers on G
Suite, like Vishnu and me,
we all want to
build products that
help you avoid time drains.
Basically, we want your
time to look more like this.
We want you to spend more time
with your clients, less time
on your administrative work.
To do that, we actually
needed to understand
what your day, as a sales
professional, looks like.
So we looked at what an
average sales cycle looks like.
We saw six main stages.
For the sales reps
in this room, you're
probably more familiar with
this cycle than we are,
because we're not in sales.
But studied it pretty closely.
We identified time drains
within each stage, everything
from the prospecting stage
to the stage where you close
the deal with your client.
These time drains,
individually, look small,
but in aggregate,
they actually keep you
from spending time
with your customers.
Vishnu will now walk us
through the sales cycle
and explain how G Suite apps,
that I mentioned earlier,
would help you avoid
these time drains.
VISHNU SIVAJI: To
illustrate these tools,
we thought we'd walk
through a scenario.
So I want to introduce Selena.
She's an Account
Manager for Rainier
which is an outdoor adventure
company based in Seattle.
Rainier makes a lot of
products, but they're
very excited about their new
launch of a brand new water
bottle called Fresh.
So Selena is now going to go
and work with a lot of clients
across the US, retailers.
And she's going to
make a bunch of content
to go pitch to these companies.
So we're going to focus on what
she would do in the first two
stages of the cycle.
Here are some things
she might be busy with.
She might be busy with finding
the right set of contacts
to email.
These contacts are in
some separate CRM tool.
She's customizing pitch
decks for this client.
She's making sure
all the content
that she pitches is
actually up to date,
and she's not doing this alone.
She's working with a team
of people at her company.
Without G Suite, a simple task,
like prospecting or leading
or emailing a
client, can be messy.
You might delay responding to
an email when you're on the go,
because it's hard
to get work done.
And you might be
constantly context
switching between CRM
tools and your email.
Speaking of context
switching, how many of
you look at a screen that
looks like this every day?
Something with, like,
10 tabs open at a time.
That's a lot of people.
OK, 15 tabs, still
a lot of people.
OK, 50 tabs 5-0.
AUDIENCE: Which browser?
VISHNU SIVAJI: Any browser.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE],
FireFox, Safari.
VISHNU SIVAJI: You
can add up all--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] login to--
VISHNU SIVAJI: So we should
talk at happy hour, after this.
I want to know how
you get any work done.
So we know that
context switching
and having multiple tabs
open is a real problem.
And in fact, there
are only two real tabs
that are relevant to Selena
right now, and it's these two.
It's her email and ProsperWorks,
which happens to be CRM app.
That's why, in Gmail, we
wanted to bring your CRM tools
right to your inbox.
And as we announced
earlier, there
are a new Gmail add-ons
coming, and this
allows you to actually
work within the context
of your email.
It's going to work
with ProsperWorks,
and we are actually going to
open a Developer preview soon.
So watch out for that link.
This is going to work on
both desktop and mobile.
So Selena can
search for contacts
saved in her
ProsperWorks account,
and she can reach out to
them within the context
of her email.
Now, the next thing
she's going to do
is make a custom pitch deck,
and this should be easy.
There's probably a format that
she's supposed to stick to.
Now in the past, you might have
emailed PowerPoint templates
back and forth.
I hear that that's a
pretty popular product
from a decade ago.
You might be pinging,
or trying to figure out
who ping, to get this template.
You might be pointed
to a shared site that
might be done half the time.
So you're just wasting a lot
of time, and all you want to do
is get started.
In Google Docs, last year,
we launched custom templates,
and this allows templates to
be centralized and broken down
by your use case.
There's also not a lot
of setup work required.
Once your admin sets this up,
trusted users in your domain
can upload new templates, and
they could be easily added.
And with just a
couple of clicks,
they're readily available
for your company to use.
So Selena doesn't have to
ping her marketing team.
She doesn't have to worry about
finding the right sites page.
And they're just ready to go.
We're actually going to
walk through a demo of this.
ZEINA OWEIS: Sure, let's
switch to the demo.
All right, so Selena is going to
start on the Google Slides home
page.
This is where Selena
sees all the pitch decks
she's created in the past.
At the very top, she actually
sees a list of templates
that the Google
Slides team has made
available to all customers.
But what's actually compelling
for Enterprise users
is the template gallery
that's specific to the domain
that the person is in.
In this case, Selena
is part of Rainier,
and in 2017, Rainier's
goal was to, actually,
sell as many fresh water
bottles as possible.
They wanted their
entire sales force
to focus on distributing
these water bottles with as
many retailers as possible.
So they went ahead
and made available
this template that can be used
by everyone in the sales force.
And they can each customize
it based on their client.
And that's just what one
slide deck looks like.
But other teams at Rainier
actually provided templates
for their finance teams.
They also provided for
their user design team.
So, as a Rainier
employee, I can go here,
to the template gallery,
the domain template gallery,
and pick the slide deck
that's relevant to me.
Selena is prepping for
her meeting in Chicago
with her customer Gianna,
a Nationwide retailer.
So she goes and picks the
Rainier Fresh 2017 pitch deck.
When she opens it, she
sees a great starting point
with slides that are
relevant to Rainier,
showing the mission statement.
And also some placeholders
that each sales rep is supposed
to fill out and replace.
There are some details about
the specific opportunity
that the sales rep
is looking for,
and even some monetary numbers
that they need to fill in.
VISHNU SIVAJI: As you may
guess, on Google Slides,
we also have a solution to
scale the process of actually
customizing these templates.
Let's switch back to the slides.
Now, you're probably
worried, as Selena is,
about finding and replacing
all those placeholders.
So she started
with the template,
but she is going to go
refer to different tools
again, copy and paste
all this information.
And she is going to
do this every time
she needs to go make a pitch.
So she's going to make
mistakes, and she's
going to have to go find the
deck again, fix the mistakes.
So it's very manual.
It waste a lot of
time doing this.
So again, we want to fight
repetitive and manual tests.
So last year, we launched
a new Slide's API that
allows you to do exactly this.
It allows you to
programmatically
customize presentations,
and we also
launched several integrations.
So one of them is ProsperWorks.
This is live in
production today.
And with a single
click, you can actually
go find each opportunity,
customize a template,
and have a pitch
deck ready to use.
So again, I don't want
to just talk about this.
Let's switch to
the demo machine,
and Zeina and I will show
you what this looks like.
ZEINA OWEIS: All right, so this
is Selena inside her CRM tool,
ProsperWorks.
She has a lot of opportunities
that she's tracking
with her various clients.
She's now working on
her deal with Gianna.
So she looks for the
opportunity, the Fresh 2017
opportunity with Gianna.
In ProsperWorks, there
are a lot of things
that can be tied and attached
to your client or opportunity.
One of them is a pitch deck.
Selena is about to start
making this pitch deck
that she's going to
present in Chicago,
and she actually uses the
Google Slides integration.
This is a tool that
ProsperWorks built
using the API's that
Vishnu mentioned.
So she selects it, ProsperWorks
asks for a template.
This is a template
that ProsperWorks
is going to use to customize
with Gianni's opportunity.
And remember this is the
template that the marketing
team made available to the
entire sales force at Rainier.
Selects it here,
customizes the name
of the customized pitch deck
that she's going to produce.
So this is [? Reena, ?]
her contact at Gianna,
and she hits Create.
What's happening
in the background
is that ProsperWorks is
replacing all the placeholders
we saw earlier with information
that's accurate from Selena's
CRM tool.
So right now, the presentation
is ready and saved.
Selena's switches back to Drive,
and this is a presentation that
was just created, right now.
If we open it, here, we actually
see all the placeholders
were replaced.
We can see the name of
the company or the client
that Selena's working with,
her contact Reena, details
about the opportunity that were
all saved in CRM tool, and even
some monetary values.
This is pretty powerful because,
in the absence of this tool,
what Selena would
have to do would
be copy and paste between
ProsperWorks and Google Slides.
And she would have to do
it for tons of customers
and, maybe, making
mistakes along the way.
So now, all this information
is ready for Gianna
to go and take the slight deck
to her customer in Chicago.
VISHNU SIVAJI:
It's pretty slick.
All right, let's switch
back to the slides.
So to quickly recap,
with the Slides API,
your organization can
make a custom workflow
that incorporates data
from several sources.
That can be in G
Suite, in a CRM tool,
in a third-party data warehouse.
And you can programmatically
bring this all together
into Google Slides.
Now, another common
problem you may have
is that you're talking about
a lot of data in these decks.
And more often than not,
you're creating charts,
and you're adding them
to these presentations.
So you'll have the same chart
that's embedded in all of these
hundreds or thousands
of documents. ,
And you might get a ping from
the analyst team that says,
hey remember when we said we
can make that bottle for $5?
Well, turns out it costs $800.
And so that's
ridiculous, obviously,
but the problem
now is that you've
got to go find each of these
charts and all of these decks
and actually update them.
Really, the source of truth
is still in that sheet.
So what we launched
last year, in Docs,
is the ability to
actually update
all of these charts
when they've been
embedded in all of these decks.
And we're actually going
to switch to a demo again.
ZEINA OWEIS: Great, so
let's see this in action.
So Selena realized
there's another data
point that would be so powerful
for her pitch at Gianna.
They've been partnering
with Rainier for a while,
and Black Friday sales
would be a great data point
to show how water bottles
sell well at their stores.
So she's got this
spreadsheet, that was actually
created by the
analyst team, and it's
tracking the sales
of different items,
different Rainier
items at Gianna.
So this is a great
chart that she created.
So she thinks, I'm going
to present this to show
that water bottles sell well.
But, of course, she's
not going to present
a spreadsheet in her meeting.
So she's copying
into her slide deck.
So I'm just copying and pasting.
And she sees this option,
an option to link the chart.
What this means is that
the data is actually
going to stay in the source of
truth, which is a spreadsheet.
Any time an analyst
changes a number there,
it would actually update
the chart in her slide deck.
So let me go ahead
and paste this chart,
place it right here.
Let me now pretend
to be an analysts who
decided to change this
number because realizes
that they entered it wrong.
See the chart now updating.
This line got bigger.
Now, they don't need
to ping everyone
who used this data, because
Selena actually, before she
presents, she sees
is that there's
an update button prompting
her to update that data
and get the most fresh up to
date data into her slide deck.
By hitting this, the
chart will actually
update with all the latest
numbers from the spreadsheet.
VISHNU SIVAJI: Yet
another example,
where you don't have to worry
about making mistakes, again.
Let's switch back to the slides.
Now, behind the scenes, Selena
is doing a lot of analysis.
She's estimating
each opportunity.
She's calculating
sales projections.
She's working with large data
sets from previous years,
because she's trying to
make these projections
for future years.
She has this problem
where she knows
what insights she needs to get,
but she just doesn't know how,
and figuring out that
how takes a lot of time.
This is why in G Suite we
want to bring machine learning
and intelligence
into our products.
The goal here is to
really empower you
with tools where you
know what you want to do,
and you just know how to do
it, and we'll, basically,
figure out the how.
One of the products
is Google Sheets.
Last year we expanded on our
Explore tool, in Google Sheets.
We can now suggest charts
by recognizing patterns
and extracting interesting
trends in your data.
This is pretty cool.
You can even ask
questions in language
that makes sense to you.
This is something that no other
spreadsheet tool out there
offers.
You can find features like
this in separate BI products,
but they're expensive, and
we've brought it all in just one
place in Sheets.
So let's again demo this.
ZEINA OWEIS: To
demonstrate this,
we're going back to that
spreadsheet with the data
from the Black Friday sales.
I see the Explore
button is going,
so I see what it has for me.
What we see here are
actually insights.
They're pre-populated,
and there's a search box
that I can use to search
for certain insights
that I'm looking for.
These are not your
typical queries.
Those are human
readable insights.
So even if someone
doesn't know how
to write queries
in a spreadsheet,
they can still use it.
So let's see what we
have examples here.
I can look for a manufacturer
with the lowest customer
rating.
So it's pulling here this
data.co that has the lowest
customer rating, and
it's actually showing me
what the customer rating is.
I can drop it into a slide
deck or a spreadsheet.
This might be a short
question with one answer,
but the formula behind it is
actually pretty complicated.
This is what Selena would have
had to type in order to pull
that insight, and that
takes a bit of knowledge
about how to merge columns
together, and it's just faster.
It's literally two clicks.
What you can also see are
some visualized insights,
charts that Selena can actually
drop into her spreadsheet
or copy and paste
into a slide deck.
For example, this
chart she just created
can actually be created with
one click, and here it is.
VISHNU SIVAJI: It's pretty cool.
Let's switch back to the slides.
Now, we know that the impact
of this is pretty incredible.
About one in three people
who use spreadsheets
have no idea how to
construct a formula,
and you just saw that formula.
I don't know how
to construct that.
This is a perfect
example of that computers
are quite good at.
So we brought the power of
natural language processing
into Sheets, so that we
can convert your sentence
into the right formula, and
give you the answer right there.
Sheets is not the only product
where we brought intelligence.
We brought machine intelligence
to several G Suite products.
Another recent example
is Quick access
in Drive, which is now
available in Team Drives.
What we're able to do is learn
from how you and your team
work together, and
we can understand
what's relevant to you at
different points in the day,
or different days in the week.
So given that, when you take
out your phone and you open up
Drive.
You go to a Team Drive.
We can actually
recommend content
that's trending and important.
Our goal, again, is to
make it seamless for teams
to get what they need.
Impact again, pretty incredible.
It's being used for about
close to 40% of file opens,
and for each file open, we're
saving you 10 seconds of time.
These savings add
up and, obviously,
the bigger your team is, the
bigger these time savings are.
So speaking of teams,
Selena's working with a team.
She's collaborating on this
deck with a set of people
at her company.
Did someone say
real-time collaboration?
I thought I heard real-time.
All right, so thanks to
real-time collaboration,
she doesn't have to send
various versions of this deck
back and forth.
In the past, I've
created drafts,
and I've named it draft
one, draft two, draft final,
draft final for real,
no for real this time,
no let's go back five days
sorry let's do that again.
It's painful.
But this is how real
time collaboration
works in Google Slides.
They are working on
the deck together,
all at the same time, making
changes all at the same time.
This document is super active.
You'll see that they're
adding comments.
They're resolving comments.
They're creating
product compositions.
It's pretty powerful.
It really changes
how teams work.
It changes how companies work.
It means that
projects get completed
in days, instead of weeks.
And we want to bring this impact
to as many people as possible.
And Zeina's going to talk more
about how we plan to do this.
ZEINA OWEIS: Great,
so as Vishnu said,
we wanted to bring the
productivity tools that we
demoed today, in Docs,
Sheets and Slides,
to everyone, even if they
don't use Google Drive.
What this means is that we
want to give customers access
to these tools, even if they use
is a different storage provider
than Drive.
How many of you here have
worked at organizations, or even
currently work or organizations,
where you store your files
outside Google Drive.
I know I've worked in the past
at organizations like this.
Great, well, previously
if you worked
at one of these
companies, actually,
you couldn't use any
of the Google Docs
features we showed you.
But now, you can still benefit
from all these great tools,
while benefiting from third
party storage providers
and their workflow
tools as well.
So last year, we announced our
first partner in this effort,
in this storage integration
effort, with Box.
And earlier at Next, we
announced a new integration
with Citrix.
We're working with Citrix to
allow our joint customers,
for Google Docs and Citrix, to
actually bring their Docs files
and store them to Citrix.
And also leverage powerful
workflow productivity
features like Share File and
their e-signature features.
So if Selena's organization,
hypothetically, uses Citrix,
she could work in
Sheets, Docs, and Slides,
but she can still take
advantage of Citrix's built
in approval workflows,
like ShareFile e-signature.
All right, so Selena,
so far, has used Gmail,
coupled with her CRM
tool with Gmail add-ons,
to communicate with her
existing and new clients.
She identified the needs
by leveraging intelligence
features and Sheets.
She visualized these
insights with charts
that she embedded into slides.
And she also
collaborated effectively
with the rest of her team
with real-time collaboration.
Before she presents
the offer, she
is looking to change the layout
of a couple of her slides.
And I'm sure all of you
have been in Selena's shoes,
pushing pixels around.
You probably spent
more time doing that,
making content look
good, then thinking
about what the story of
your slides should be.
But we don't want it to be
that way in Google Slides.
And that's why we built
intelligence features
in Google Slides, just like
we did in Google Sheets.
So what you can do is just
drop in your content, text,
or visuals on a slide, and
with a couple of clicks,
you'll have slides
that actually looks
so good people are going to
think that you hired a design
agency for them.
And as before, let's
see this in action.
Let's switch to the demo.
VISHNU SIVAJI: All right,
so we have a pretty good
looking slide here, but I think
I have a pretty good design
sense.
I'm going to try to
touch this up myself.
I love the color gray, and
I also love the color--
let's go with orange.
I think that looks pretty good.
I like this maroon
thing in the corner,
so I'm going to make
this match that.
That looks pretty good.
What do you think, Zeina?
ZEINA OWEIS: I don't know.
I'm seeing a few people cringe.
VISHNU SIVAJI: All
right, that's hurtful.
Let's switch this slide.
When I open the
Explore tool, you'll
see that we have an amazing
number of high quality design
suggestions.
ZEINA OWEIS: Much better.
VISHNU SIVAJI: And the
reason they're high quality
is because we actually had
a big team of designers
at Google hand-curate and
hand-make thousands of designs
that go in the product.
And with the power of
machine intelligence,
we're able to look
at your slide.
We're able to pull from a subset
of these design suggestions,
and with just one
click, you can apply it.
As you can see, there's an
incredible amount of detail.
If you look at this shape,
it's semi-transparent.
I have no idea how
to make a circle.
That's so perfect in Slides with
a text box in the center of it.
It's pretty cool.
I'm going to try something here.
I'm going to add another
image to the slide.
So let's say, that Selena
wants to add an image of a dog
on a hike, pretty
reasonable combination.
So I'm going to add the image,
and what you will see here
is the suggestions have
refreshed in about a second.
And with just a
single click, you're,
again, ready to go
out on the road.
ZEINA OWEIS: The Explore
tool that Vishnu just
demoed, if we can switch
back to the slides,
was so compelling, because
it really does save time.
We've seen that people
save 2/3 of the time
that they would otherwise
spend designing slides.
So even if design is not
part of your expertise,
as a sales professional,
you can end up
with beautiful presentations
that you can be proud of
to present to your clients.
And this is all done
with a couple of clicks.
Now we know that another problem
is to find high quality visuals
and diagrams in order to
communicate certain messages
to your clients.
And here at Next,
we're happy to announce
that the same add-on
framework, that's
available in Docs
and Sheets today,
is coming to Google Slides.
And with the upcoming
Slides add-ons,
we're going to bring
powerful third party
tools, like Balsamiq
Lucidchart, an Adobe Stock,
in order to enable you to
beef up these presentations
and pitch decks.
And here too, our goal is
to make you more productive
by helping you avoid
context switching.
So let's walk through
how the Adobe Stock
add-on will look like soon.
Selena will actually
start in Google Slides
to browse through add-ons that
are available in our store.
And if she was looking for
a high quality stock images,
Adobe Stock is a
great place for them.
She adds the Adobe Stock
add-on to Google Slides,
and it appears in a
side nav experience,
like what you see here.
She's able to browse through a
vast collection of high quality
images, within Adobe Stock.
She can even browse
icons or illustrations.
And when she finds
the image that she
wants to add to
her slide deck, she
has the option to either
preview it in the slide deck,
or purchase it through
her Adobe Stock account.
So now, not only does
she have great designs,
that Vishnu
demonstrated just now,
but she also has
high quality images
from third party providers
who are specialized in this.
Now, while presenting the
compelling pitch decks
to her customer, Gianna and
various other retailers,
Selena actually opens up the
floor for some questions.
Putting a Q&A feature in
Slides enables presenters
to not distract themselves
by getting questions
throughout the talk, but
actually maintain engagement
with the audience.
And because I want you to
be a little more engaged
with the rest of this talk, I'm
going to turn on this feature
right now.
All right, so with
a couple of clicks,
I've actually turned
on this feature,
and you see the URL at
the top of the slides,
and it's going to stay here
for the next few slides.
You can go to this URL
and submit your question.
At the end, Vishnu
and I will actually
see the questions
that were submitted.
We can see them real-time.
You can even vote on
other people's questions,
so the best questions
get up-voted.
Now, while you submit
questions, we're
going to continue
with our presentation.
Now remember Selena's client,
Gianna, the one in Chicago?
They're actually pretty
sold on Selena's proposal.
They want to carry these
state-of-the-art water bottles
in their stores.
But before they
sign the contract,
they want to resolve
just a few issues.
And that will require Selena
to share a draft agreement
with an external collaborator,
or a client, in this case.
If you remember earlier
in the presentation,
Vishnu told us about how
Selena collaborated internally
with her team.
Each time she was able to
decide what kind of View Options
she wants to give her teammates.
She can give them view
only rights or edit rights,
so they can actually help
her with the slide deck.
But Selena actually goes through
a different thought process,
when she's sharing
a file externally.
It could be pretty
nerve-racking.
There are some extra sensitive
information in the agreement.
So Selena wants to be
conservative about what
the client can do with the file,
once she shares it with them.
She can give them view only
access, but what's so powerful,
in Google Docs, is that she can
prevent her external client,
Gianna from further
downloading this file
and forwarding it to others.
This is something
that doesn't apply
in the world outside Cloud.
Because the world
outside Cloud, you
attach the file in an
email, once you hit send,
the recipient can do whatever
they want with the file.
They can download it and
send it to other people.
For certain clients,
she can even
set permissions that expire
after a period of time.
So she knows she's going to be
in Chicago for a week, that's
when she wants to
collaborate with her client.
She can set it for
seven days only.
Google Docs just
strives to give you
full control over
the sharing access
controls that you
have for your files.
And what's great is
that this is actually
all done within a
couple of clicks,
and it's a pretty slick UI.
So how about we demo this.
Switch to the demo.
VISHNU SIVAJI: Great,
so you see it here, this
is the final contract
that Selena's drafted.
And if you go to
the Sharing dialog,
you see that she's shared
it with a couple of people.
And with just one
click, she can set
it to expire within seven days.
With that, she's pretty
confident about sharing
this file.
ZEINA OWEIS: Great, so let's
switch back to the slides.
So once Selena shared the
file, her client, Gianna,
is ready to collaborate.
And the old-fashioned way
of collaborating with files,
sending them back and forth, as
Vishnu has explained earlier,
is not the case in Google Docs.
With Google Docs,
Selena can collaborate
with external clients
in similar ways
that she collaborates
with internal clients.
But we know collaborating is
different than negotiating.
When you are
negotiating, you also
want to put suggested
comments, except them, maybe
also reject them.
This is otherwise
known as red lining.
And soon you'll also be
able to accept or reject
all changes at once.
So now that the open
questions have been answered,
both parties have done
crafting agreements,
it's time to sign the contract.
This brings us to the last
phase of our sales cycle.
Now the G Suite ecosystem
is full of partners
who are actually specialized
and have years of experience
in certain areas.
We know that they're
great approval
workflows out there and
e-signature workflows
out there.
And we want you to
be able to use them,
even if you use Google Docs.
And one of the many e-signature
partners is DocuSign,
and it's recommended
for a G Suite partner,
and it has more than 100
million users in 188 countries.
Last year, the team
at DocuSign announced
an Android add-on, and
this year, here at Next,
we're very excited to
announce that DocuSign is soon
integrating even
further with G Suite.
We're pre-announcing
their upcoming real-time
in Google Docs, and this
is what it will look like.
When you're done
editing a document,
you can actually kick off
the e-signature workflow
in the sidebar,
here in Google Docs.
You can specify who
will be signing,
and you can send Google
Docs through DocuSign
at the end of the flow.
So to recap, what we did
here is bring powerful tools
like DocuSign to
you in Google Docs
and save you time and
reduce context switching.
And that brings us to the end
of the Selena's sales cycle,
and the water
bottle apparently is
going to be distributed in
more retailers than ever.
And as you saw, there are
real-time collaboration tools,
there are some intelligence
features, built into the suite,
that can help you
avoid time drains.
Vishnu and I want
you to go from here,
and check out even
more tools that we
couldn't cover in this talk.
You can find out more about G
Suite in the G Suite Learning
Center.
The URL is over there.
You can also hear from
our G Suite customers,
telling them how G Suite
worked best for them.
And that would be at the
transformation gallery.
They are all over there.
If you're more about
trying things out yourself,
and less about
reading on a website,
you can actually pull
out your mobile device,
open the Sheets app, and try
out the Sheets Explore tool.
That brings all of
Google's intelligence power
into an app, a productivity
app like Google Sheets.
[MUSIC PLAYING]